I can't help myself the music gets too
good how's it going Reza
welcome back to activate you should play
this game by just walking as normal as
you possibly can
what were you doing okay we got to find
Stasia Tommy by [ __ ] normal as you
puff I shut up oh [ __ ] there see me hi
what happened let's go in here
okay normal you're normal come on dad
let's get through all this junk so we
can get out of here why is that guy just
staring at me
alright well okay I guess we got to
learn the way of deciding how fast can
you map the world's kelp forest shut up
what the hell is there your sister's
there it is oh is that all I gotta do
well god dammit that took me forever
okay
oh there didn't what's the point if Oh
hahaha hey there little boy ah don't
worry
octopuses I mean humans have
teleportation skills surprise
[ __ ] don't look at me like that
I'm not a monster
I'm very comfortable here I think I
might just stay anyway there we go what
the [ __ ] is a lemon Aria don't tell me
what to do do have any Bros in Lamoni
midoriya no oh it's coming it's coming
it's coming
wait oh we're gonna get the worst time
that's for [ __ ] sure
plus it's not we and I do all the
[ __ ] work
alright I've kept you my side help you
happy a piece of [ __ ] he did what I was
gonna do what a little sweat I taught
him well
I really am comfortable here though I
think I'll just say now let's [ __ ] these
balls over [ __ ] tired of you and [ __ ]
go okay go yeah I bet I need it later
alright well for now let's go hi man
um are we gonna go hopefully it all mine
so much [ __ ] tentacle in my [ __ ]
okay
the way you sound excited like that is
really awkward especially for octopuses
for [ __ ] wait what okay stop it head
we did that one grab the top of the Kel
what is a calve tell me what is a calve
kill police male and female spores to
reproduce get a male and female spore
into each sea floor soil plot oh god I
have to learn and [ __ ] oh my god oh my
god I have no idea what's going on
so if he knows how babies are made
nice it's very this is that it's just so
wrong is the most wrong thing I have
ever heard
don't tell me what fine
god you're stupid it's like I have to do
everything outside okay what is this a
touch the top okay I can do that I'm
trying dad grab I got it
yay that lag though yeah all right what
else do I gotta do
I bet on faster than sanic baby look at
this you just got a run sexy it's all
about being attractive in life boy
that's the most valuable lesson I have
ever taught
I'm trying but it's not so easy cuz I
don't know if you noticed but I'm a
goddamn octopus I can't damn it if you
weren't my son you'd be dead how about
that okay one step at a time maybe yes
so easy oh my god are we done please
tell me we're done okay we're done cool
why what do you guys like a nice what's
so suspicious I'm not a nom nom nom nom
nom I'm not an octopus iswe just gonna
go down here
whoo yes faster what up [ __ ] what up
I'm not an octopus grab the actors hi hi
hey let me throw let me throw I know
karate [ __ ] I know karate don't make me
hey man hey man do you come here often
I'll grab the artists hand why did you
tell me oh god oh god okay oh come on ah
what what is happening Oh God but I'm in
love with this hotter it's a prick
what no no honor hi I'm not an octopus
or anything it's really excited to be
here really excited to be here man it's
gonna walk normally as a normal human
yes just gonna go over here yep this is
how humans walk
cuz I'm obviously here it's great what
whoa what is this how did he get up
there
get to the top that's all I gotta do all
right well that's fair enough
ah where's your sense of dick I hate you
I'm stock I'm stick call an ambulance
oh I'm fine no I could grab this Jess
and then I swing a crash I'm still sick
though still think I don't know what I'm
doing with my life
really though ah Yolo Yolo that's what
I'm doing with my life say on the other
side I'm down here okay cool I don't
know what you're talking about but you
are not my son anymore oh hey baby hey
hey have you ever been in with him like
a shut up shut up shut up just shut up
shut up shut up shut trying to head on
ladies hey hey girl have you ever been
with a man who can do this huh
you haven't been it with a Mane that can
lick lick your face with his genitalia
that sounded really perverted
unintentionally okay you need that you
need a stop I hate you you're not my oh
my god I'm here okay
easy peasy lemon [ __ ] look I just gotta
gotta make it to the top oh god oh god
oh god I'm in it oh my god I'm a genius
what is no no no no not to trampoline I
got damn it no I'm I'll oh god no don't
fall off oh my god this is so hard
what am i oh no no no no no no [ __ ] yes
yes yes yes
oh my god it oh no no who built this
bridge it's an [ __ ] no no no no hang
on Octopussy Oh what oh I feel again hey
girl what's that hmm okay I'm gonna try
this way
I think this way is easier I think I can
if I really put my mind to it turns out
I can I'm not capable of [ __ ] okay where
is this [ __ ] going okay I don't care
about you that made that oh oh you're
gonna let her through but not me this
game is racist and sexist [ __ ]
[ __ ] this game it is racist again
[ __ ] except we both what okay now
just now I'm just namche it now I'm just
octopus I mean it's the most hardcore
game I ever played [ __ ] up okay just
[ __ ] speed run my [ __ ] into
infinity cuz god damn you just gotta go
with it sometimes in laughs you just
gotta go with the flow you can't say no
to my [ __ ]
no no no no no get to the top bed how do
you how do someone man bounce stop
throwing things that may you pay such
[ __ ] son what I'm I'm really stuck now
aren't I
let's take me to [ __ ] Narnia I don't
know I'm stuck I had to reset the
[ __ ] day
okay go don't go fight the power fight
the power fight my ass oh god I hate
life oh the [ __ ] are you doing here you
little piece of [ __ ] kill him kill him
this game is racist yes yes I do quite
frankly believe I deserve to don't slide
out don't slide out you scope du skulle
yeah Oh shucks my doctor dick oh you
gotta let go man you gotta let go with
your feet there you go ah I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you what am I even doing
here
wait are you telling me I need to go up
in the hole I'll just wait until I hit
the hole it has to be someone kind of
octopus advantage here yeah yeah I can
okay yeah yeah
you see that [ __ ] you little [ __ ]
yeah that's right yeah that's right
you're in my domain now baby steps baby
steps okay we're just gonna Yolo on
three one oh god I don't want to know
yes ah you're not getting [ __ ] you think
this is a game you think this is funny
you think this is funny huh you think
this is all funny hey nice tie god damn
it just hope you enjoyed this episode
Alice fine look like you enjoyed
watching hit the sky cover thing I see
you brezin next one stay awesome love
you